-Our first guest tonight
is a two-time
Academy Award-winning actor
you know from films
such as "Forrest Gump,"
"Philadelphia,"
"Saving Private Ryan,"
"Castaway," "Apollo 13,"
and so much more.
He stars in the movie "Elvis,"
which is coming to theaters
June 24th.
Let's take a look.
-Is there a lawyer
representing the family?
-Oh, unnecessary.
I am of the firm opinion
that family is the most
important thing in the world.
In mind of that,
I have taken the liberty
of making these contracts out
in the name of
Elvis Presley Enterprises --
a family business.
And I was thinking
Vernon Presley,
business manager.
-What do you think, Daddy?
-Oh, well, uh...
I like it very much, son.
-Ah!
[ Laughs ]
-Please welcome to the show,
the one, the only,
Tom Hanks, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hey, thank you!
Thank you!
-Welcome to the show!
-By the way --
All right, thank you.
Thanks!
The -- The perfect clip.
Was I in that clip?
[ Laughter ]
'Cause everybody's like,
"Wha? Wha?"
-Well, you do disappear
into this character, Tom.
-Oh, I don't disappear.
I am laid beneath
five hours of makeup.
-Was it five hours?
I was watching the film,
and there were moments
where it was really
just your voice and your eyes.
-Well, when I met -- excuse me.
I got to turn off my phone.
-Thank you so much. I'm sorry
we didn't tell you earlier.
-No phones.
When I first met
with Baz Luhrmann, I said,
"Can I ask you a question, Baz?"
"Yes, yes. What is it?
What is it?"
"Why are you talking to me about
a movie about Elvis Presley?
'Cause I don't see any --
who am I gonna play?
J. Edgar Hoover?"
-Right.
-"Ike Eisenhower?
Where am I in this?"
And he said, "No, this is about
Colonel Tom Parker and Elvis."
I said, "Ah, all right.
Could you do me a favor, please?
Show me what Colonel Tom Parker
looks like?"
'Cause I'd never seen
a photograph of him,
never heard his voice.
You know, I think,
"Colonel Tom Parker --
what is he? Does he make chicken
on the weekend?"
-Of course.
[ Laughter ]
-"Is he a big, big cowboy hat
and a stentorian voice?"
And then
he showed me a photograph,
and so, again,
I had another question --
"Why is it you're talking to me
about playing this guy?"
-Were you offended
when he showed you the photo?
-I was not offended.
I said, "Ah, you see me
as a man
of infinite opportunity."
[ Laughter ]
All you have to do is say,
"Tom, Tom, just sit
in this chair for five hours,
and we'll do all the rest."
And that's
what we did every day.
And everybody says,
"How'd you get through
five hours of makeup?"
Like this.
This is how I got through
five hours of makeup.
[ Laughter ]
That's it.
That's all you have to do.
-That's the secret.
-Cut to that clip
that you just saw.
-So, it's interesting
you say that,
'cause I obviously knew the name
Colonel Tom Parker,
but I realized I had not seen
a photo of him,
and I had never heard
what he'd sounded like.
But do you think that's common
for people, that they never...?
-Well, I think
the Elvis aficionados --
We were just down in Memphis.
By the way, every person
in Memphis knows everything
there is to know
about Elvis Presley --
and FedEx, oddly enough.
They just know everything.
[ Laughter ]
-So you're a huge deal
down there.
-Oh, man, I can't -- I can't
buy a beer in Memphis, man.
I cannot buy a chicken pot pie
in that town.
It's all brought over to me.
So, no, they do know,
but I'm just --
you know, I only knew Elvis
from really silly,
kind of enjoyable movies.
Elvis, to me, was the star
of "Girls! Girls! Girls!"
and "Fun in Acapulco."
-Uh-huh.
-"Spinout."
The music -- you know,
I was a pre-Beatles -- that --
I turned 7
when the Beatles came out,
and they wiped out everything.
Everything prior to the Beatles
was Doris Day.
-Yeah.
-Or, you know, Rosemary Clooney,
"How Much is that Doggie
in the Win--" including Elvis.
You know,
that's just the way it is.
So I had no knowledge of it.
And finding out
that Colonel Tom Parker's name
was not Colonel Tom Parker --
it was actually
Andreas Van Kuijk.
He was from Holland.
He jumped ship.
He did not have a passport.
He was an illegal alien
and was named some sort of
bogus Kentucky colonel by the --
I don't know, the Lexington
city council one day.
Turned that into a military rank
and called himself
a technical advisor.
-When you got --
This is the first time
you worked with Baz Luhrmann,
and obviously,
you've seen his films.
I can only imagine
what it's like to work --
They're so unique.
Was working with him
what you expected?
-Baz makes coffee nervous.
-[ Laughs ]
He is the hardest-working guy
there is.
And this is so funny.
So we --
Austin, who played Elvis,
he worked on this movie
for two years.
I was on it
for about six months.
And he would --
he would always be saying,
"I don't want to see --
What page is this now?
You just wait.
We'll wait, we'll wait.
You'll see new pages
in two weeks.
Two weeks,
there'll be new pages."
There was never two weeks.
No new pages ever came in.
We'd come in
at the beginning of the day.
He'd say, "Okay, today's work.
Have you seen the pages?"
"Yeah, I have."
"Well, we're not doing them.
[ Laughter ]
"We're gonna do these --
we're gonna do these instead."
It was like every day was
a performance of "La bohème."
There's 8 million people.
There's no time and space.
There's no lot --
I mean, as an actor,
it's, "Okay.
What's the geography
of the scene?
What's the logic of the time?
What's the --"
Threw that all out the window
because he jumps around,
and it's like -- there's no
shuffling of the cards with him.
It's just go, go, go, go.
And we would get to it.
We'd be working all day,
and we'd be --
you know, we'd be in the --
You know, about take 17,
"Baz, do we have this yet?
Take 17?
Are we done yet?
I know we've done it differently
every time."
He'd say, "No, no, it's perfect.
Perfect.
Absolutely perfect.
I'm going to use it.
It's in the movie.
Just one enhancement,"
and then we'd do it
16 more times...
[ Laughter ]
with more enhancement.
But the liberating quality
of that meant that
we couldn't do anything wrong.
Everything was just grand.
So you never got a sense of,
"Oh, that --
Can we start again?"
You never had to --
Because guess what --
you were starting again.
[ Laughter ]
There was no need to ask
if you were going to.
-There were -- the Vegas scenes
were such a wonderful
cinematic experience.
Seeing it on a big screen,
which I was lucky enough to do,
it was --
you felt like you were there.
You felt like you were seeing
something special in real time.
And again, Austin,
I can't say enough about
the transformation he did,
as well.
I know less --
I don't want to give him
too much credit because it
wasn't five hours of makeup.
-No, he did have a lot of time.
He was in makeup
as long as I was.
We were in COVID protocols,
so we didn't get --
Half the making
of the movie is --
Okay, one half
is free sandwiches
and haircuts anytime you want.
[ Laughter ]
That's a big thing
about making movies.
Don't tell anybody.
[ Laughter ]
Otherwise everybody's gonna
want to be in the movies.
-Oh, yeah, everybody's
gonna want --
Once they hear about
the free-sandwich part, yeah.
-That's all they want.
That's it.
You know, you know, a ride to
the airport when you need one.
That's a good thing, too.
But the other thing is the hang.
The hang of everybody
making a movie, man.
It's just like, I mean,
the very first time Edison
put people together
to make a movie and [trills]
they said, "Hey, this is
a pretty good hang."
But with the COVID protocols,
we were not allowed
to see each other.
-That's a real --
-So I was with --
I was like this,
and there was Shaun,
and there was Jason,
and there was Brittany behind,
holding my head.
So, particularly
in the Las Vegas Hilton scenes,
there's easily 300 extras there.
They're all dress extras.
We're all ready,
and we are all waiting
for Elvis to show up.
And he's on the other side of
the gold curtain, the whole bit.
And when you're waiting
for 45 minutes and the --
Can you guys just do that --
that audience-waiting
"huzzah buzzah?"
Pretend the show hasn't started.
Just talk amongst yourself.
[ Audience murmuring ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Right.
There was that sound, you know?
By the way, good job, guys.
That's fabulous.
[ Applause ]
-They really --
-That's good, that's good.
So, we're waiting for him
to come out all morning long.
And lo and behold, if we didn't
get the whole shebang --
♪ B-u-u-uh buh ♪
Can you give me some timpani?
Kind of like
"2001: A Space Odyssey"?
You know...
♪ Bum -- ♪
[ Drumming ]
Yeah, that.
And so we're all getting paid
to be there, right?
And we're all gonna be there
all day long.
But every time that began --
one more time.
[ Drumming ]
Yeah, great.
And the curtain would suddenly
come up,
we'd start hearing the band,
my God,
it was like we were transported.
300 people were going gaga.
And we got to watch the show
again and again and again
and again and again.
And every time,
it was just magic.
-I can imagine.
I will say the whole time
I was watching it --
I'm genuinely saying this --
I thought, "I cannot wait
to see this again."
-We forget the power of Elvis
in a room in Las Vegas.
It's kind of, like,
developed a kind of like a --
more like a --
-Yeah, kitschy, yeah.
-It was not in the day.
Anybody around the world,
if they could jump through
a time-and-space-continuum
machine,
"Where would you
like to be today?"
"I would like to be in Las Vegas
seeing my idol, Elvis Presley.
That is where
I would like to be."
And they all went.
-Well, I have a lot more
to ask you.
-Bring it on!
-We're gonna stick around.
We'll be right back
with more from Tom Hanks.
-Huzzah. Huzzah.
-Huzzah, clap.
Clap, clap, clap.